except for today it's different because
it's not a fantasy this is my real life
in the Netflix original to all the boys
I've loved before we fell in love with
Laura Jean and her insatiable teenage
hormones in the sequel PS I still love
you the romantic team comedy levels up
in maturity as we follow our favorite
characters into a brand new year at high
school this time around Laura Jean and
Peter are no longer pretending to be a
couple and everything seems
picture-perfect that is until an old
flame comes back into the picture and
chaos ensues I guess I just want to know
how mortified they should be today we'll
be taking a closer look at the film and
will be pointing out 10 things that you
might have missed throwbacks we think
that the reason why to all the boys I've
loved before is one of Netflix's most
viewed original films ever is because it
plays with nostalgia throughout the film
the first movie follows a classic story
of a misfit love and what happens when a
jock falls in love with a Wallflower
while watching this tale is all this
time we couldn't help but think that
we'd found ourselves in a modern version
of a John Hughes movie in PS I still
love you the film opens with Laura Jean
dancing around her room to the song then
he kissed me by the crystals not exactly
a modern day top 40 hit you would think
a teenager would be listening too right
it seems as though Laura Jean is a
romantic as we watch she proceeds to
engage in classic rom-com tropes like
playing dress-up dancing with her
boyfriends frame photo then finally
falling onto the bed totally overcome
with love this scene brings to mind
multiple movies such as The Breakfast
Club grease and pretty-in-pink of which
feature scenes where young women use
their bedrooms as our personal stage
when large jeans little sister
interrupts saying this is not the time
to be fantasizing about living in an 80s
movie we are convinced that our theory
holds wait the hills are alive another
moment in the opening scene that we
think is worth mentioning is when Laura
Jean puts the curtain over her head like
a bride does this actually look familiar
to anyone you can't put your finger on
it we'll help you out and The Sound of
Music when Maria is feeling inspired to
assimilate into the Fontan Trapp family
she takes the curtain into her hands and
drapes it over her head in the exact
same manner you can see it side-by-side
it's almost uncanny we believe that this
was no
accident and that the director wanted to
pepper in yet another nod to another
iconic movie though own the sound of
music
Maria goes on to make drapes into
clothing for the children we are pretty
sure Laura Jean isn't that crafty a
similarity between these two characters
however is that they have both gone
through hardships before this point and
are in a period of inspiration and
forward movement we think of both films
the playfulness with the curtain
symbolizes joy hope and reinvigoration
adventures and babysitting though it
only happens for a second you can catch
lower gene watching the flick Adventures
and babysitting at the beginning of the
movie if you haven't seen the movie no
worries it's about a babysitter who must
battle her way through the big city and
track down the kid she's meant to be
looking after though the plot is very
different from PS I still love you it
still deals with the antics of dating
the chaos of being a teenager we think
this is yet another example of Laura
Jean swooning for anything over
romanticized and trying to get her own
life to mirror her favorite films the
foreboding Lantern the second
installment of the series Laura Jean
navigates a couple official firsts with
Peter including her first real kiss and
her first real date she dresses in a
beautiful red dress and is picked up by
her knight in shining armor Peter comes
in with a bouquet of flowers and takes
her to a fancy restaurant something
Laura Jean says she had been dreaming
about ever since she was a little girl
after dinner Laura Jean takes the reins
and brings Peter to what appears to be
an impromptu Lantern Festival she
instructs Peter to write a wish on the
lantern to be sent into the sky the
weird thing is Laura Jean wishes for the
very relationship she already has which
Peter is quick to question she responds
saying that she doesn't want them to
break each other's hearts as if she
already knows what's in store for them
we think that this moment is her
basically jinxing their entire
relationship and setting them up for
failure Laura Jean doesn't trust that a
good thing can last and thinks that what
she has is too good to be true
clovers in my eyes right after Laura
Jean receives her handwritten response
from her long-lost love John Ambrose
she's uncertain of what to do after many
attempts at writing a letter and
grappling with her feelings she abandons
her writing and questions whether she
should tell Peter about this new
development consider
and adorable what am I saying I can't
say that directly after this moment the
song clovers by the Brooklyn based band
berry plays for those of you who don't
know this track will fill you in the
first line of the song is I know where
to go which is what we think Laura Jean
is secretly thinking at this time though
she flounders over getting in touch with
John Ambrose
we know that in her heart she already
wants to connect with him the general
vibe of the song is like a waking dream
with bright piano and simplistic guitar
carrying the tune essentially is the
perfect soundtrack to a blossoming crush
the chorus repeats clovers in my eyes
which we think points to Lord gene
harboring her secret crush as you
probably already know the clover
symbolizes luck but it also symbolizes
good omens for hope and love for the
finder coincidence we think whoever was
in charge of the soundtrack for this
film really got it right love knocks you
off your feet it's pretty hard to forget
the first kiss between Laura Jane and
Peter in the first movie well on the
track field Laura Jean knocks peter to
the ground and plants one on him in an
attempt to ward off her sister's
ex-boyfriend in PS I still love you
however the tables are turned and Laura
Jean is the one who is knocked to the
ground during her visit to the old folks
home she surprised to see John Ambrose
and is so taken aback that she slips and
falls as she comes to John Ambrose
stands over her much like she did with
Peter in the first film though during
the first movie Noah Santino who plays
Peter a master following a 5.5 million
people it was a fan favorite on the
Internet it is in this moment that we
see the competition between the two boys
begin the John is unlike popular Peter
he is both bookish and charming making
life all the more complicated for Laura
Jean in an interview Santino said that
when you have someone like John Ambrose
up against anyone anyone else in the
competition should be afraid very afraid
and we couldn't agree more
hufflepuffs unites and her letter to
John Ambrose Laura Jean mentions that
she thinks that herself and John Ambrose
would be in Hufflepuff if they attended
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry for those of you who aren't
up-to-date on your house history don't
worry we've got you if you're sorted
into Gryffindor chances are your go
getter you're seen as pure apart
you're probably brave and you're
definitely popular to us this sounds
like the house Peter would be sorted
into if you're Hufflepuff however you're
basically underrated it seems to be the
house for people who don't really have a
home but they find home in each other we
think that the fact Laura Jean thinks
that her and John Ambrose belong in this
category there's nothing too
AFET they seem to have a lot in common
unlike her and Peter who are sometimes
at odds and her flashback of Halloween
Laura Jean remembers dressing up like
french toast when John Ambrose went as a
deviled egg we think these two outcasts
are pretty and perfectly perfect rock
bottom after Laura Jane finds out about
Peters history with Jenn she's totally
and utterly crushed she returns to her
home and swaps her cheerleading costume
for subdued grey sweats throughout the
movie her outfits are on point she can
often be spotted wearing bows in her
hair jewellery all over and every little
thing in its place in this scene however
things fall apart her sadness is
reflected in her costume and it extends
to the state of her room as well usually
lar Jean is the kind of kid that you
would never have to tell to clean her
room when she hits rock bottom however
so too does her cleanliness her bedroom
seems to explode with unwashed clothing
and mess the lighting also reflects her
mood usually the bedroom is well lit
with fairy lights but now all lights are
off and her internal light itself dims
her hair is unbrushed and she even swaps
her happy fruit loops for boring
Cheerios when large enos sad
the whole world around her takes on a
shade of gray after this she engages in
some late lip-syncing as she drifts down
the hallway mouthing you can think that
you're in love when you're really just
in pain talk about teenage melodrama
girls just want to have fun after Peter
and Laura Jean meet at the aquarium he
takes back the locket they say goodbye
in front of the tank of jellyfish so we
could go on a mild rant about how the
jellyfish could symbolize Peter stinging
Laura Jean and an act of betrayal will
spare you this time at this point in the
film things are beginning to turn around
the Lord Jeanne still looks a bit
disheveled
she starts wearing color again though
her room is still a bit of a mess her
fairy lights get flicked back on she
grapples with honesty both between her
and Peter and with herself in the
background a cover of girls just want to
have fun play softly though in the
original version Cyndi Lauper makes you
want to stop what you're doing and dance
in this version does the exact opposite
the song slowed down feels incredibly
moody and yet still hopeful we think
this relates directly to what Laura Jean
is going through though she's feeling
down somewhere in her heart she wants to
lighten up she can see the light at the
end of the tunnel and just wants to
dance again Cinderella story throughout
the film we see large and engaging in
one of her favorite hobbies baking and
unlike most people who bacon clothing
that might get a little messy Laura Jean
opts for more
see dress and plays the part of the 60s
housewife we think that her choice to
opt for fashion / function here is her
trying to play to fantasy life she can't
have though she fancies herself as some
kind of romantic is full of nostalgia
for yesteryear it all catches up with
her eventually the first movie she tries
being in a fake relationship with Peter
in order to escape her reality and by
the second film she tries to hide her
feelings for John Ambrose in both cases
it doesn't end up so good for her her
true feelings rise to the surface and
she realizes she needs to be her genuine
self in order to figure out how to be
authentic so at the end of the second
film she seems to have learned the
lesson of acceptance rumor has it
there's another film in the works we are
eager to see where the third film will
take us and if Peter and Laura Jane's
love will stand the test of time
stay tuned did you notice something that
we didn't were there any easter egg do
you'd like to add to our list if so
sound off on the comments below as
always thank you for joining us and be
sure to subscribe to our channel for
future videos